All right, it's time for Drew's News,
your daily news smoothie with an extra plop,
plop of the good news protein powder.
And with me at the desk
is my trusty co-pilot, Rossy Ross Mathews.
That is one healthy smoothie, everybody, hi.
Hi, guys!
(audience applauds)
And a big day around here, Drew.
Well, speaking of two scoops of high-powered protein,
joining us on Zoom are two men who need no introduction,
legends, comedians, actors, and writers,
who are now co-hosting an incredible new podcast
that takes you behind the scenes
at the institution that is "Saturday Night Live."
Please welcome the ones and onlys,
Dana Carvey and David Spade.
Wow.
(audience cheering)
Hey.
Hello.
David!
(audience cheering)
This is insane.
Great hair day.
Right?
Hey, yeah.
Yeah.
Wow.
Hey, how are you?
I'm so good.
There's so many things that you've put out into the world
that are so wonderful.
And you have this new podcast
that really does give you a fly on the wall
from legends from the almighty institution.
I was lucky enough I got to come to your show last week.
Thank you so much for having me.
Yes, you did.
You were wonderful.
Yes, you were awesome.
And one of our favorite guests.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, no joke.
Can I ask you both a quick question?
Like I'm just gonna pick two things that you did
out of the top of my head.
Like, David, when you came up with Hollywood Minute,
how did that one come about?
'Cause I think about it all the time.
It's one of my favorite things I've ever seen.
I miss it, I love it.
I think the quick answer is that in those days
there was just "People Magazine"
and everyone was sort of just fawning over celebrities.
And I was a guy on "SNL"
that no one knew from Arizona, younger.
And I would read the "People Magazine' at the desk
with like Bob Odenkirk and other writers
and just go make fun of people.
Oh, look at Michael Bolton,
you got long hair in the back,
but we all know what's happening on top.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I know you sold 8 million albums,
but I don't know anybody that has one.
And then, I would just talk out loud.
And then, he goes, "Why don't you turn that into something
for the news where you can just deliver 'em rat-a-tat-tat?"
And then, we did that.
And then, Lorne said, "Why don't you do it again next week?"
And I was like, 'cause you know,
Lorne's like the dad that you want to like you
and I wasn't doing unbelievably well in the show.
So it turned into a running thing
and it helped me stay on for a couple more years.
Now like, Dana, Church Lady for one.
Yes, yes.
I mean, come on.
Come on.
I mean.
(audience clapping)
Where was the impetus idea light bulb for that?
I'm not totally sure where it came from.
I was playing where I met my wife,
in the Haight-Ashbury converted laundromat,
a little comedy club, and I would riff a lot.
And I looked 12 at the time.
I looked younger than David Spade.
And when I came on stage,
I could see the audience kind of go, "Whoa."
And so I started doing
that condescending teacher attitude of, "Well, well, well.
Apparently, they let little children into the audience,"
theater, whatever.
So that's where it came from.
And then the condescending, it became church ladies,
the ones who ran the church.
Well, this attitude is fun to do.
So it'd be like, "Oh, 'The Drew Barrymore Show.'
We have a little set don't we?
And we have little microphones we talk into
but we don't care too much about Jesus."
I didn't mean to offend.
That's just the Church Lady, not me.
No, no, that's Church Lady, she's weird.
That's the lady she's kind of mean,
I'm nice.
Yeah.
(upbeat music)